good evening everyone welcome to the
Columbia art and Technology lectures
which are Co organized by the digital
media center here at the School of the
Arts and by the computer Music Center
which is part of the department of music
my name is Mark tribe and I'm director
of art and technology here in the School
of the Arts Columbia's history with
Arden technology actually goes back a
long way
to 1958 when Vladimir was the Chesky and
otto luening co-founded the Columbia
Princeton Electronic Music Center which
then over the years developed into the
computer Music Center which is really a
hub and nexus for various kinds of
artistic experimentation with emerging
technologies here at Columbia but
scholarly inquiry related to art of
Technology actually takes place at a lot
of places around the universities I've
been finding out in my first year here
as I go around and try to uncover
pockets of interest and sympathy
particularly in the Graduate School of
Architecture planning and preservation
there's a lot of interest in hybrid
cultural practices that engage with
physical spaces and emerging
technologies and different kinds of
information architectures also in the
department's of our history and also
anthropology and there's also a lot of
surprising not surprisingly in the
Graduate School in the School of
Engineering and Applied Sciences both
inductive engineering and computer
science so the purpose of this lecture
series is to kind of try to draw
connections between all these different
areas and to help develop a critical
understanding of the relevance of art
and technology to not only the
traditional disciplines of artistic
practice like theater and performance
and visual art that are exploring here
at the school the arts but also to the
term wider range of
and a party tonight I would like to
welcome our fifth and final speaker for
the spring 2004 semester
Ricardo Dominguez Ricardo is a
co-founder of the electronic disturbance
theater CDT a group that developed
virtual City and technologies in 1998 in
solidarity with the southeast of
communities in Chiapas Mexico DDT's
swarm action was presented at ARS
electronica info horror festival in 1998
in Linz Austria he is co-director of the
thing which you can find online at BBS
pain dotnet and it's a really great
resource for experiencing and talking
about and reading about various kinds of
Contemporary Art particularly new media
art and a former member of the critical
art ensemble which developed the theory
of electronic civil disobedience back in
the 80s
Ricardo recently presented a performance
entitled hacking the art of abstraction
at the Reina Sofia Museum in Madrid
Spain and he just did a performance
entitled the fourth world war at the
international theater festival in Krakow
Poland
Ricardo's essays have appeared at sea
theory which is an online journal for
critical theory and in corpus delicti
performance art of the Americas which
which is published by ravage in 2000 and
edited by cocoa Cusco is a professor in
the visual arts division here in the
School of the Arts Ricardo is editor of
electronic disturbance theaters
forthcoming book hacktivism network our
network art activism to be published by
a ton of media press in 2005 the art and
technology lectures will continue in the
fall with a focus on open source culture
intellectual property technology in the
arts
we'll see many of you there then
starting late September and you'll find
this lecture and the previous past four
lectures online at the digital media
center website which you can find by
googling usually prefer starting in the
darkness but we have a little bit of
light so we'll have to give in to the
light I usually like to begin at the
beginning but this time I'll begin
before the beginning in the most
important work done by this up at least
us a book called the book of mirrors the
fourth World War and the defeat of
neoliberalism written by Don dorito of
Lacan Dona the most famous invisible bug
in all of the la campaña
and in that book it begins with the
prelude which is the story of the book
of mirrors so I'll begin before the
beginning with that story in the
darkness before the darkness and the
infinity before the infinity and the
time before time there were seven
goddesses and these seven goddesses and
the time before time and the infinity
before infinity in the darkness before
darkness wandered and had never seen
their reflection or each other in this
darkness before the darkness and this
infinity before the infinity in this
time before time but these seven
goddesses were extremely lucky in this
time before time in this infinity before
infinity in this darkness before the
darkness because they had really nice 70
style shag carpeting and all of you know
if you've been at an orgy recently
raised her hand have you been at an orgy
well too bad
but if you
oh gee and really nice 70 style shag
carpeting you know that the body starts
to chemically recharge itself as it
moves through the weaving developing a
certain kind of tension a certain type
of electricity well it just so happened
in this time before time in this
infinity before infinity in this
darkness before darkness when these
seven goddesses who had never seen
themselves the reflection or each other
were wandering in this seventy styles
shag carpeting developing attention of
the body attention of the self and
suddenly quite by accident two of the
seven goddesses and this time before
time in this infinity before infinity in
this darkness before the darkness
touched lips and suddenly a spark a
piece of light a piece of reflection
something quickly emerged and of course
these southern goddesses in the time
before time and the infinity before
infinity in the darkness before darkness
snatched it out of the air from between
their lips and held it in the palm of
her hands and slowly she opened it and a
little bit of life began to emerge
perhaps that light of the dawn or that
light of the dusk that light that keeps
the darkness that slea dreams by night
or the white that walks by day from
bumping into each other and the other
goddesses seven of them gathered round
and they looked at this slight bit of
light that had developed out of the
tension of their bodies on this really
nice shag carpeting southern D style and
slowly they passed it from palm to palm
pressing it gently over and over the
southern goddesses and the time before
time in the infinity before infinity in
the darkness before darkness and as each
one of them slowly put the palm down
they saw a mirror had emerged each one
of them had a mare in each of their
hands they slowly placed each mirror on
top of the other and out of this came
the book of mirrors they put the book
down on that really nice seventies style
shag carpeting and each one of them bent
over and turned the leaf over they
stared into their reflection each
one of the southern goddess and this
time before time in this infinity before
infinity in this darkness before
darkness saw themselves for the first
time and at that moment of instantaneous
reflection
seven times seven times seven times
seven gods emerged and as each of the
seven goddesses looked into one of the
pages that they'd created seven times
seven times seven seven times seven gods
appeared in this infinity before the
infinity in this darkness before the
darkness and this time before the time
now these seven times seven times seven
gods were very different from the first
seven goddesses these guys really loved
to shake their ass around they liked to
drink plus all they like to play
Nintendo all night long and well you
know the party really got rockin and
rollin and you know usually about 3:17
if the party is going really well what
happens somebody's big ass not some down
right just such a thing happened one of
the seven times seven times seven gods
was shaking his ass around and what the
book of mirrors went into the infinity
before infinity to the darkness before
the darkness into the space before space
and shattered completely seven times
seven times seven times pi shards hit
everything everyone through the eyes of
the goddesses through they got eyes of
the gods and out of those shards came
out for mothers and for fathers the bat
women and that men and from there seven
times seven times seven we were born and
in each of us is a piece of the book of
mirrors and when we are born it is
broken into seven pieces starting here
moving down to the bottom of our toes
and sometimes have years sleep you can
still feel that orgy going on and that
really nice 70 style shag carpeting and
it feels rather good well I was dreaming
of this just as I was about to be born
this nice 70 style shag carpeting and I
thought wouldn't it be marvelous to be
born into that
or G and as I emerged you can turn the
light on now it's always good to emerge
into the light I was born in Las Vegas
Nevada the perfect 1970 shag style
gorgeous
so is primo real estate the military
entertainment complex was right there
virtual capitalism had bloomed around me
seven times seven times seven i was pure
neon I understood military entertainment
complex quite well and for having
emerged out of this infinite before the
infinite and thus darkness before the
darkness and this time before time my
dad gave me an RCA portable television
just for being born what a guy and there
in my crib he put this RCA
black-and-white television would
probably weighed more than all of the
university here and he turned it on at
that moment screen old space came right
into my eyes broke everything that was a
you know available for me to understand
screen l space was beautiful I used to
love looking at it licking it drinking
it I loved screen all space more than I
love my mother more than I loved my
father more than I have anybody probably
that I could ever look here I loved
screen l space and I used to spend
endless amount of time just kind of
dribbling on it you know I would try to
catch the Flintstones as they went by
you know with my crayon I could never be
fast enough and so it was this intimate
relationship with screen ality that I
think I I really interjected at a very
early stage but I was about
two-and-a-half years old I became
fascinated by the seven tubes in my RCA
that I would turn on they would glow and
these days there were tubes right they
were warm kind like the shining light
and I started to wonder these seven
tubes here before me so beautiful so
warm bringing me such screen all space
this must be love this is what love
looked like these seven tubes and I felt
like I needed to touch love I needed to
lick love well it's difficult as you
know because you know the grid is there
my little chubby two-and-a-half-year-old
hands then quite get in there so as I
was contemplating licking love touching
love my mother came like gave me my warm
bottle of milk as mom's often do and it
was warm and wonderful and as I was
about to taste that I said Paul perhaps
I could take this warm love of my mother
and touch the warm love inside I wonder
what would happen if I took my warm milk
and poured it in there I did and you
know what happens when you lick love
with a warm milk of your mother it
blows up I was in such pain my
screen O self test was completely
destroyed the first mirror in myself was
broken and basically everything I have
done since then is to reenact that
moment to take the most ubiquitous
technology available like warms mother's
milk and destroy the highest levels of
Technology it's this action that I feel
is a space of love rather than a space
of hate so in the space of disturbance I
will now come briefly to the more
academic me because this is an academic
situation so it's about hacktivism and
this hacktivism is about a dialogue
between me almost me and almost another
me so if you start getting confused as
to which is me and almost not me and
almost another me you can join the club
because I'm also very confused as to
that but more importantly than
everything else you must remember
hacktivism was initiated by the Sabitha
space a community without electricity a
community without telephones a community
that doesn't even speak Spanish as its
primary language 28 Mayan communities in
the most southern tip of Mexico and
Chiapas in the jungle of the Lacan Donna
were able to subvert all the theories
between 1991 and 1994 about what cyber
war was what cyber terrorism was and
created something completely other than
that so I'm now going to try to go into
scholarly mode and you'll have
- forgive me a moment as I go into my
scholarly mode
I believe scholars are very serious
people they speak from a certain
position and that position is usually
one of grids now I'm not trying to be
too logical here I'm not trying to
establish an eschatology for those who
are worried about the ontology of our
current condition I certainly don't want
to impose a teleological condition to
your binary condition but for the moment
I would like to kind of compress the
twentieth century in a way that perhaps
will make sense to some of you it
doesn't make sense to me but it may make
sense to you here of course is the
beginning of the 20th century you can
even say 1900 entrepreneurial capitalism
steam power property rights nature as
other conquest of nature nationalism it
has its own disease tuberculosis the
beginning of film mechanical realism
high art frame possession image and of
course the old worker Vanguard the
leftovers of the last century of course
it is here that perhaps we can quickly
consider that it is the Nexus of fucose
Society of discipline right the
Disciplinary culture it really comes to
full fruition here at this particular
point because it is there that one
creates the Nexus of what is
disciplinary culture which is as we all
know a prisons hospitals and schools
none of which you are involved in I'm
sure but this is disciplinary culture
now around here we can begin to see the
beginning and end of World War two
culture and the emergence of monopoly
capitalism electronic power corporate
rights alien as other third world
conquest imperialism it has its own
cancer television emerges instantaneous
modernism artists commodity screen
mediation collage consumer and is really
at this kind of Midway that you get the
lose kind of reshipping of cuccos
disciplinary code culture if you will to
one of control culture control culture
really being bound by this emergence
between electronic power and micro power
and of course down here at the bottom
the the Vanguard is consumer Vanguard
very much a society of control consumer
Vanguard
it's the emergence of this society
wherein even the unconscious comes under
consumer control if you will I'm sure
most of you never by your unconscious at
the stores or by your unconscious online
but supposedly in delusion theory even
the unconscious is a part of the control
mechanism produced by monopoly
capitalism and the emerging
multinational capitalism of course here
we we reach kind of the emergence of the
early 80s late 70s the emergence of
multinational capitalism micro power
copyrights knowledge as other conquest
of intelligence multinational and has
its own disease isn't it wonderful how
we can coordinate our diseases and our
grid coordinates aids a computer logical
iconic post-modernism plagiarism chip
interface in Malacca and the course
affinity groups affinity groups are a
product of a lot of interaction that I
had with activate coalition to unleash
power during the mid 80s and of course
at this point we start shifting away
from delusion positions of the society
of control and we start moving towards
the society of performativity as we move
to the Society of performativity we
start moving away from multinational
capitalism to virtual capitalism
nanotechnology DNA rights biology as
other conquest of existence
globalization a gray goo syndrome
you have to forgive this this was a
painting I did in 1985 so I will correct
myself it is green goo syndrome right so
for those of you please forgive that
wetware a fractal rhizomatic hypermedia
biochip interjection chaotix and of
course the virtual Vanguard and it is
here of course that we drift into the
final edges of the Society of
performativity especially that as
enunciated by avital Ronell John
McKenzie lash and several other
theorists in terms of the development of
performativity it was this particular
grid that I originally painted in
Tallahassee Florida at the edge of a
barn it was my first painting or
probably my last painting as you can
tell and I was trying to explain to
people driving by why this was happening
and it happened that in 1981 through 85
of course cyberspace began to emerge as
a sone of metaphors as a zone of
representation of course you remember a
1981 Iran comes out right elucidating a
representational structure of what
cyberspace will be like 1983 wargames
comes out Freaker culture comes to the
foreground right you guys remember
wargames where he takes over no rad
NORAD and normal starts a nuclear war
and of course 1984 very important
William Gibson writes Neuromancer have
you guys read Neuromancer raise your
hand well maybe some of you have good
for you there he defines cyberspace not
as a condition of software or hardware
or even a condition of infrastructure he
defines cyberspace as a consensual
hallucination right so this was
interesting to me in 1984 and I felt
that I think I I was ready to understand
what the stage was for this consensual
hallucination and one of the primary
elements that led to the development of
disturbance Jefferson gestures for me
was the seventh chapter
Neuromancer if you guys remember in the
seventh chapter of Neuromancer there is
a problem that arises for the two
dominant political agents or in this
culture one is of course case the hacker
right who has the penultimate access to
port access to the inside of the
informatics culture the other agent in
this cyber culture is Molly millions
who's a cyborg so in a certain sense
it's again binary women are cyborgs they
intrical men are hackers they in a
certain sense interject the informatics
but the question arises in Chapter seven
as to when they are faced with an
informatics bunker that has such deep
ice around it what happens in a society
politically that is the cyborgs cannot
enter through the door of the
informatics bumper it will not let her
in no matter how amplified and
interjected she is with the technology
the bunker will not let the hacker case
go in that is because the ice is so
thick now of course what happens is that
they have to turn to somebody else and
the people that they turn to are the
Panther moderns the Panther moderns are
not hackers the Panther moderns are not
cyborgs they are theater troupe and
their job is to create multiple zones of
reality as they say 10,000 realities and
so I decide at that time that I will
work with the emerging group in
Tallahassee Florida called critical art
ensemble seven of us and we will become
Panther moderns we will not be hackers
we will not be cyborgs but we will
create the space for political agency
that perhaps will allow these new agents
to emerge easier said than done
my scary self please forgive me I'm
interested in hacktivism is a form of
interactivity as a type of activism that
targets technical infrastructures as a
way of hacking social groups attached to
them at the heart of this interest lies
the challenge of resisting emerging
forms of performative power a power so
supple that it can embrace and encourage
diversity creativity and even an even
transgression for those committed to
social activism and critique it's it's
as if the critical edge we've been
standing on has become narrower and
narrower until the only option left is a
certain leap it's here that losing
brought that ease notion of line of
flight becomes crucial I have always
been I have always attempted to inject
the organic into technical
infrastructure as part of the new
performative matrix in order to seduce
the technocratic class hackers and
system administrators specifically into
a politics of code Beyond code the
electronic disturbance theatre has been
pushing the possibility of code politics
and street activism mirroring each other
via digital stuff a dismal digital
Sabitha smoke is an electronic gesture
that moves networked ontology from its
binary space of communication and
archiving to a theatrical strike zone
for mass nonviolent direct action this
has allowed EDT to create a dialogue
between net hackers net activist net
artists about a performativity that is
not digitally correct
hacktivism making connections across
diverse fields is crucial and I think
performance is the password for doing so
although the passage is tricky tricky
post-world war ii specialisation has
generated many performative alien sees
and that it practically takes rocket
scientists to sort them out in the arts
and humanities performance elicits
notions of resistance and social
efficacy in the post Fortis
organizations
performance cults have arisen stressing
efficiency through creativity and in the
techno sciences high performance values
of technical effectiveness help launch
space race the space race and is now
pushing the glories of computers at one
trillion operations per second
performance however in the past two
decades these cultural organizational
and technological spheres of performance
have begun to mesh coming in to
increasing contact and conflict and
perhaps compromise for me in this
meshing these messy meshing signals call
for the full-blown emergence of a
performance stratum an auto historical
formation of power / knowledge that
displaces the disciplinary mechanisms
analyzed by Foucault paradoxically the
norms of performative power include the
demand to transgress system limits so as
to measure those limits test the
environment and constantly innovate one
implication the integration of diversity
is being supplemented by the diverse
diversification of integration under
such conditions the tactics of
resistance must obviously change and I
think activists have been among the
first to realise this
came to New York in 1991 what I was
looking for was a platform that would
allow me to create a space for
electronics or expedience
nice to create a space that allows one's
voice and body to create its presence in
the world
but when they did it strong and directed
and that's awesome electronic civil
disobedience is a non-violent direct
action online
that follows the theory of zero and on
civil disobedience but was then
developed by Gandhi one Luther King felt
during the eighties aids coalition to
unleash power
we never destroyed a server we never
change anybody's webpage
we never hijacked their name or domain
name
it was in the hills of Chiapas in 1994
that the first shots were fired in the
information war despite being without
electricity or telephone the Zapatistas
took the revolution online issuing a
call to arms across the internet for
others to join them in a worldwide
struggle against economic imperialism
the movies
disturbance theater or a moan first to
eat the corn
what is this apathy studies those who
can take into the part of the poetic
gestures the gestures of information war
which cross the boundaries of what is
for instance on January 30 2009 the
world had something pista air force
attacks Mexican military nobody knew the
stuff of theses even had planes nobody
even knew the stuff at least this could
fly but if you read the story suddenly
you discover that these sympathies their
Air Force work paper airplanes made of
many different colors inside were
messages of peace so what the soldiers
were shooting at where are these paper
airplanes and there you have this
enactment of the simulation of the
gesture which creates this magical space
where indeed there does exist a
something piece that Air Force because
what you're trying to get out is what
the sum up needs to say is information
war that is words as war not words for
war inspired by the zapatistas ideas
Ricardo and his crew launched their
flood meant to as the paper airplane of
cyberspace now one of the elements
that's important in all of this is that
digital Sufism emerged as a network
nothing that I have ever done has ever
been by myself
I've always been part of groups that is
critical art ensemble act of electronic
disturbance theatre the thing so
everything that I say is always with a
we that is it's a completely porous
space that I'm speaking about now and
one of the things that happened was a
one minute after midnight 1994 as the
NAFTA went through the large trading
bloc between Canada the US and Mexico
was that the SEPA theses emerge from the
lakum done' and came down armed ready to
die in the traditional Maoist lemonis
condition but what happened was they
ripped into the electronic fabric quite
by accident shattering their own
identities their own histories their own
teleology if you
well within a few minutes they began to
understand this commandante Ramona said
that they had ripped into the electronic
fabric quickly and efficiently and they
discovered that the cyber theorists like
Ron Felton Aquila were quite wrong that
one did not need to have access to
physical infrastructure as was necessary
for cyber war one did not need to have
some tactical knowledge that is how to
command Hardware through software one
only needed semantics semantics is words
as words so when they emerged at this
point it took him 12 days to reverse
their particular trajectory they went
away from the condition of military
latin-american tradition the tragedy as
they call it and they in turn became a
digital Sabbath Easter community and it
was in 1994 at the first intergalactic
encuentro at the network table that the
Sabbath Easter's presented the need to
develop something beyond networks the
intergalactic Network they said all post
media direct action cells must pursue
the instabilities of technologies even
before they become metaphors we must
move into areas that seem like the
impossible before they even gain
presence among the protocols of the mesh
it is within these chaotic sectors that
actors among civil societies in search
of leverage anchors will find
opportunity for greater disturbances and
force multiplication for voices without
power
once minor communities of autonomy have
sensed the balance shifters
they must be harnessed those who wait
for the decentralization of these
instabilities will lose the small
windows available for the development of
micro mass disturbance gestures we must
always already be seeking out the flow
of uncertainty
beyond the overyou scientific discourse
and technologies at hand we must go
beyond networks biotechnology and
nanotechnology let the mesh spend its
time tweaking these possibilities
instead we support East us continue to
break the mirrors of power and to move
elsewhere so it was here this
Abell that we've decided to create the
digital Sabbath Easton Network the
digital southeast the network would be
based not on the protocols of the
network which was already driving around
Felton Aquila quite mad over at the RAND
Corporation or you can probably read
Sapa thesis and social network as their
response to the reversal of their
theories in terms of the Sabbath pistas
the suffered theses are calling for
ubiquitous technologies like paper
airplanes shock perhaps Mother's Milk to
subvert other conditions
so in response to this I started
developing with many others this network
Arica reading Turkana intent Olave
communication communication alternativa
or the intergalactic network of
alternative communication one of the
outcomes was that it grew quite rapidly
in many different languages and we were
able to process a great deal of
information so quickly that we were able
to leverage this particular semantic
force against the Mexican government and
against the United States and force them
to speak directly to the Sabbath
Easter's within a matter of months
something that doesn't happen very often
with Latin American trajectories usually
what happens is that people are fairly
quickly snuffed out out of a dialogue
but this did not occur now one of the
elements of the intergalactic network
was that we were emphasizing
communication and documentation but
already in the mid-80s with critical art
ensemble we had been speaking about our
plagiarized ideas of electronic civil
disobedience and I already knew that
electronic civil disobedience would not
come from the hacker community they were
only they were only interested in the
politics of code qua code it wouldn't
come from the activists because their
Luddites to begin with they wouldn't use
the technology to develop this sort of
action and for good reason and of course
the powers-that-be would never develop
this because it wouldn't be in their
interest also we knew that activists who
pursued actions in the street were going
the wrong direction the streets were
dead they were dead capital but the
Sabbath ystos were very ready to begin
to listen to this idea of electronic
civil disobedience and they
quickly wrapped the network table around
it it was just the question as to how
would be done when it would be done and
what the trajectory would be at that
time I started to having a conversation
with the net strike movement they didn't
have that name at that time in Italy a
particular group called the anonymous
digital coalition and in 1980 and 95
they contacted me that they had an idea
and because of certain translation
problems I didn't really understand what
they were trying to tell me but it had
something to do with the URLs and it had
something to do with the refresh button
finally we were able to have a dialogue
I did a show called the Robin ology the
southeast deport action and I might be
through artnet web I think this was 96
97 that it happened and it was there
that I was using Robin a lucky the
accident only accident Mayan play that
we have it's a battle between the sky
King and the rain King and I used the
early progressive video and progressive
audio which then became real audio real
video to communicate with the southeast
the communities around the world and
projected up to MIT what happened was
that we were finally able to translate
what the anonymous digital coalition was
speaking about and they were saying the
idea of net strike was to use the URL
and the refresh button that is we would
go to the Mexican government URL and hit
the refresh button over and over and
over manually right thus creating a
disturbance I thought this was a grand
idea and we discussed it and started
developing it what happened was that we
weren't quite sure when we should
manufacture it at the largest level and
this didn't happen till 97 December 22nd
with the massacre at octi all or 45
women and children were killed by
Mexican paramilitary troops we launched
the southeast the flood net it was
developed by Carmen kurasov who had been
my system administrator up at MIT
Brett Stoll bomb did the Java applet he
was a young net artist out in San Jose
for Nia and also Stefan Rey a scholar
journalist and at that time working on
this dissertation at NYU on information
war the drug war and the Safa thesis and
what happened was that when I sent out
this alert translated by the anonymous
digital coalition Brett Starr bomb came
back and said you know I can make a
little JavaScript that can take into
account how many people come and we
don't have to use our little fingers and
hurt them
I said Fantastico but I hate HTML I hate
HTML conceptualism I don't want to be
annoyed by it and so I introduced them
to Carmen / assic Carmen wanted to
create an electronic monument that would
elucidate what had happened so they came
back and they gave me the Sabbath Easter
flood net flood net is kind of an
endless rain that doesn't stop and you
get very very wet and we launched it in
1998 for Mother's Day and we had about
18,000 people join us and many people
around the world sent us a little JPEGs
that the Mexican government said I'm
sorry so many people are requesting this
page that we cannot respond to you
please come back later we felt this was
a victory the next day we were in The
New York Times and it said the activists
have arrived and from that point on the
kind of media sphere began to eat up
what we now call the virtual sit-in now
one of the elements that played itself
out was that the Sabbath Easter flood
net used traditional net art gesture 404
file not found which was down here and
that is Jody org used it to create kind
of whimsical conditions of 404 files
that is when you look for something you
can't find it we twisted it to a
political condition that is we would
have the Mexican government thus justice
thought HTML exists on this Mexican
government web server the server would
respond justice does not exist on this
server does democracy and so on
now it built into kind of a large
landscape of action as as it developed
we were then invited by ARS electronica
to come do an action for them this was a
particularly in
staying action and that it was the
largest one that we had done was on
September 9th 1998 and what was
interesting was that this performance
allowed you to see who wanted to control
hacktivism in terms of this performative
matrix that morning I got a call from a
Mexican government and very clear
Spanish that said we know where you are
we know what you're doing we know where
your family lives do not go downstairs
do not do this you know that this is not
a game and they hung up
Stephane ray and I were all there we
were very excited by this because he
created a nice mess on scene
it created a sense that here telephony
would them the first part of the
internet was being used to amplify some
control of online culture then as we
went downstairs to start the flood net
we were surrounded by heart a group of
Dutch hackers who said what you're doing
is pure evil if you do this we will take
you down this is worse than script
kiddie culture and we agreed that this
was worse than script kiddie culture and
we wanted to have a dialogue with the
digitally correct community who was
anonymous who used code effectively as
opposed to electronic disturbance
theater who was transparent use code
that was not effective but symbolically
it had a certain efficacy we said we
will have the dialogue with you but
we'll start the performance we started
the performance then enough time a very
important critical and activist
community called us in and said what you
guys are doing the electronic
disturbance theater is pure evil it will
destroy activism online as it has
originated that is communication and
documentation you're just going to bring
the powers-that-be down one of us down
on all of us
so as we say in the u.s. three strikes
and you're out Mexican government said
no hackers said no net time said no we
went downstairs we looked at flood net
flood net wasn't working the Pentagon
had launched an offensive information
war weapon at us we were contacted by
wired.com telling us about the situation
so there you saw you know the grid of
power of who wanted to control it
Mexican government hackers activists and
the Pentagon and it was interesting to
have that
kind of performative matrix play itself
out we then received an email from the
Harvard Law School of electronic law
wanting to know if we wanted to sue the
Pentagon because they broke the Posse
Comitatus law of 1878
and we weren't quite sure if we should
do that and we weren't quite sure
because we really didn't have an ending
to our performance right it was a year
long but we were really banging our
heads and we thought suing the Pentagon
is interesting but what do I you know it
sounds too much to us we were overburden
we then were very depressed and we were
about to leave ours electronical and we
received an email from the woomera
desert an indigenous community there in
Australia said can you do a virtual
sit-in for us the Western mining
corporation is doing illegal toxic
dumping and uranium mining who said
we're very sorry we only work for this
up at East us I know we said god that's
stupid that's really stupid why does
should anybody have to ask us for this
so at that moment we decided we would
launch the disturbance developers kit
HTML pages that would allow anyone
anywhere to do their own virtual sit-in
we launched it from fake shop.com out in
Williamsburg at one minute after
midnight in celebration of the seventh
year of declaration of lock-on don' 20
minutes later a queer nation launched
the virtual sit-in against God hates
calm two weeks later the
International Animal Liberation Army did
virtual sit-ins against to
pharmaceuticals in Switzerland and they
shut down the network's they were so
afraid and this was really the emergence
of hacktivism a word that was imposed by
the New York Times and I didn't really
like but one could either struggle
against it so electronic disturbance
theater who proposed electronic civil
disobedience as opposed to hacktivism
kind of decided that hacktivism would be
a burrito term that we would stop it
with just about anything we wanted and
so we would use it interestingly enough
activism emerged with many groups
electro hippies in the UK Federation
random action in France s11 down in
Melbourne and what occurred was a
blooming of a digital culture that was
beginning to mesh itself with the
development of Street politics
specifically in Seattle of course while
there was 50,000 people online
there was a virtual set in a 500
thousand of people online so there was
an i submerging of data bodies in real
bodies and the last element of this
performance that we didn't expect was
that we were invited by the National
Security Agency to come do a performance
for them exactly one year after ours
electronic on September 9th 1999 has
anybody done a performance for the NSA
raise your hand have you been at the NSA
oh that's too bad
well it's an interesting space there's
nothing there it's kind of like this
only much grayer the performance was a
stefan ray on a large Kafkaesque podium
reading very clearly and doctor'll like
dissertation we did this this this and
this I had the two screens on one was
alpha bill by Godard and which a poet
makes a computer cry on another screen I
had soup come on Dante Marco speaking on
the need to develop an intercontinental
network of struggle and resistance and I
was in the middle with myself at Easter
Mass
telling stories of Mayan technology at
the end of the performance
there was no applause there was a kind
of a low-grade disregard about
everything and then senator Specter who
just went again and Pennsylvania extent
up and he looks like the smoky man and
x-files
and he said young man you are the
beginning of the electronic Pearl Harbor
and I said no sir I believe the Pentagon
is the beginning of the electronic Pearl
Harbor they launched an offensive
information war weapon that actually
worked
speak to any hacker and he not activists
they will tell you that this hTML is
technologically inefficient ineffective
less than script titties it is basically
HTML conceptualism well I don't know
what that is but if it's not illegal it
should be immoral well HTML
conceptualism does bring out immorality
and a lot of people but one of the
elements that occurred was that there
was a gentleman from Naval Intelligence
who was quite perturbed and my constant
reference to mayan technology and he
said what the hell is mayan technology
and i said
the consumer with you know I the big
nose was walking at the edge of at the
whole of our village that one side was
Lamar of the ocean the wisest and
deepest of the supper thesis at the
other side was dumb Dorito the most
famous invisible bug in all of the lock
on Donna who had written the book of
mirrors the fourth world war in the
defeat of nil neoliberalism in 1968
while started studying at the Sorbonne
when we encountered Pedrito a
two-and-a-half-year-old the whole of all
he hit the bottom of my boot well I've
been the big nose I looked and said only
estas haciendo what the hell are you
doing down there Federico better if you
looked up at me and said I'm picking up
the men and women who are going to the
consultation of the 21st I said muy
bueno petite about what the hell do you
have in your hand there
he said it's my trap but it's not a
truck pivotal be realistic that is a
rock wall
dammit it's not even a rock it's a
purple better Vito looked up at me and
said you know pig nose that is your
problem yourself at least us have no
imagination
bbbb toxic encephalopathy I turn to
Lamar of the ocean and I said that is
true we separate these must have no
imagination
I turned to don't do it on the dorita
looked up admits it how many times have
I told you if only you read the proper
discourse in the broth yes
don't Dorito only we read as much as you
I'm sure we would develop in an
imagination we continued marching into
the Kahala ball village there were the
elders the men and women deciding which
man in which woman would go to the
consultation of the 21st benedito was in
the middle plane with his pebble when
suddenly polish a commander tie plain
blue and yellow roared over us on the
other side from Mexican helicopter from
the Mexican army Obama said the war in
Dan was deafening but this did not
disturb the community and dialogue they
merely raised their voices
I continued but in the middle of the
village pathetic to look up and say yeah
I say enough is enough
zoomy went into his home zoom we came
back out faster than I have ever seen
any child move and in his hand was a
stick and he said now watch me he lifted
the stick above his head and what
suddenly the commander type plane made a
half circle and headed back toward its
base of the Mexican military helicopter
slid away to the edge of the village
sound returned back to normal the
community quietly went on with its
dialogue Pedrito satisfied with the what
he had done through the stick down
picked up his rock I'm sorry I mean his
truck enough he went peepee because it
was a doodle well I'd be in the big nose
I walked over I picked up the stick I
gave it a scientific viewing its weight
its length its texture its smell its
taste
I turned to Lamar and said it's a stick
Lamar turn to me and say it's a stick I
put the stick in my pocket and we
continued marching out well we
encountered coming in commandant a tacho
and commandant attached I said hey big
nose what the hell do you have in your
pocket there I took out the stick and
Lamar of the ocean turned - come on Doc
they thought you and said Apophis was
the Mexican helicopter that had slid to
the edge of the valley I tried to
remember what the delicto had done I
lifted the stick above my head away
suddenly the the helicopter became a
giant tin vulture it fell straight to
the ground the clouds parted the Sun
came up and everything became like gold
and marzipan done the NSA did not enjoy
the story they wanted to know who was in
control and I said oh you mean who tells
us what to do and they said yes oh
that's easy at that point they asked us
to gently get out now one of the
elements that is important of all this
is that tactically we didn't want to
convince the NSA that what we were doing
was HTML conceptualism electronic civil
disobedience or anything else that would
be too difficult we only wanted to
convince two specific people dr. Dorothy
Denny representative of Clinton's
information war community and wind sure
how the head of information war now for
the bush regime we wanted to convince
those two individuals at the end of our
performance dr. Dorothy Denning seemed
quite convinced a week later before the
house arms Committee on cyber terrorism
she specifically mentions that the
electronic disturbance the error in the
southeast us are developing methods of
electronic civil disobedience which are
part of the American history since
bureau of civil disobedience and has
little to do with cyber terrorism cyber
crime or cyber war on the right side
with short i writes a book a month or i
mean a few months later called cyber
shop 2000 in which he says that the
electronic disturbance theater is a
history of civil disobedience as it has
developed in united states its HTML
conceptualism who the hell knows what
that is but the pentagon was wrong this
is not cyber war not cyber crime not
cyber terrorism now this was very
important but we didn't know how
important once we had to face the
question of hacktivism post 9/11
perhaps the distinction between high and
low five performance can be thought of
in terms of major and minor performance
a distinction I make using the losing
what that ease concepts of major
dominant performance dominant forms of
art and science and minor resistant
processes of research and
experimentation key here is not the
opposition between major and minor
processes but the structural
entanglement of minor performances with
in major performances it seems to me
that the physical syntactical and
semantic loafing interventions just
mentioned outlined all occur within high
performance networks indeed they must
occur within them in order to produce
the desired effects of D stratification
and resistance in short the creative
lines of flight must head straight into
the performance stratum in order to
discover its outside its atmospheric
realm of effects intensities and forces
what is the desire of performance within
flight performance here in this
atmospheric realm norms may be these
norms may be stratified in two mutations
but also mutations may become stratified
in two norms it would be interesting to
trace how physical syntactical and
semantic interventions each unfold on
the three levels of major performance
level number one is this core pride
discourse practices words and gestures
the level for most artists still work
formal and conceptual experimentation
the next level of socio technical
systems social groups and organizations
such as cultural educational and
corporate institutions and the last
level the Anto historical strata
formations of power / knowledge that
largely define what is for any given
Society over long periods of time
minor performances operate across three
levels to destroy us 5 the forms and
functions of major performativity moving
from discourse practices to socio
technical systems requires not only
formal and conceptual experimentation
but also forging of short-term alliances
between dispersed groups and
institutions and thus electronic
disturbance theater and hacktivism must
be interdisciplinary and perhaps even
extra disciplinary collaboration becomes
essential Network
in between net hackers net activists and
net artists moving to the level of Anto
historical strata not only requires
situating today's knowledge formations
and power mechanisms in relation to
those of the past it also involves
tuning in future all patterns of
stratification in order to anticipate
and indeed rehearse future modes of D
stratification for me the most striking
thing about the electronic disturbance
theatre flood net and sup at least the
tribal port scan technology is not its
messages but its potential as an unheard
of writing machine it is literally
dispatches from the future
you might even say this up at least a
flood net is an active prop that not
only is tuning in future all patterns
but rewinding the manifest destiny of
the techno challenge it achieves this by
bearing witness to the structural
inadequacies in the present digital
support these most deeply anchored in
our current condition at the same time
digital sympathies Moe has always
already been a dispatch from our future
and lead the Sabbath East has often
speak of themselves as an intergalactic
protocol but the most but most
importantly the misses they sent us let
us know that millions of real people
around the world are still living
without the most basic necessities and
rights at the dawn of the 21st century
the future for them looks as horrible as
the past we just left behind like much
of the world today the communities in
Chiapas Mexico are without voice under
the stratification of the future is
defined by neoliberalism the Sabbath
Easter's are an untimely weight of being
on the future they use the current
writing machine of the networks to
perform counter realities which link
forgotten phantoms of the past to future
forms of life they are ghosting the
present by haunting the future it has
been this line of light that has created
the possibility of Klaw cross-platform
performativity as solidarity for EDT
between socio technical systems and the
extra disciplinary dialogue necessary to
create a space for invention and
resistance on a globalized level to
counter global i--i the globalized level
but one of the main concerns for me
about what occurs in the process of
liftoff into the new stratums of high
performance of this will to perform or
else is that only the engines and code
become the focus of the event that in
moving from
discourse practices - socio technical
systems and beyond we forget that the
ships that we drive are being built by
13 and 14 year old girls working 12
hours or more in the border zones of the
new economy
these girls are becoming fodder for the
high-performance drive or as we used to
say in the 80s they are virtual roadkill
it is too easy for the nexus of
formations of power / knowledge to
forget them and many others EDT
sympathies the flood net and the more
recent stuff at least the tribal ports
can are an attempt to make the mesh and
its future grid remember them constantly
within their own infrastructure as you
can see the local system doesn't like
this up at least a tribal port scam the
tribal sport scan was used by the
electronic disturbance theatre during a
border half in 2000 against the border
police basically what we did is we sent
poems in via their ports we don't think
that sending poems via ports is illegal
even though they told us that playing
with ports was basically in the
beginning of kind of a practiced action
if you will but again we don't believe
that poetry is against the law in terms
of its digital mapping at the station in
the ports but obviously the local
community here does since in 53 seconds
they're going to shut us down because
port scans have been of course made
illegal by a homeland security or are
almost reaching levels of illegality and
I guess finally I will go back to a more
academic predisposition so excuse me a
moment I like to end with kind of a
series of minor academic conclusions one
is to look at the past which i think is
always important in terms of developing
a scholarly view of contemporary culture
and also of course forecasting briefly
as to new layers of
we say well it's difficult to be hopeful
about a hopeless future but let us speak
about the future
excuse me I you know like most academics
I need to use I'm sorry I'm also blind
as an academic excuse me
usually I you know for academic purposes
I get to know a lot of you personally
now don't I
you know the the board is quite
important in terms of analyzing things
academically and you probably want to
take notes because you will be tested on
this all right all of this work really
is an enunciation of 5th century Athens
at the center of the square students
what is at the center of the square of
5th century Athens well you haven't been
doing your reading right the gore right
did you guys do that ok
and at the top of the Agora is basically
the dominant logos community or Plato's
virtual Republic right those individuals
who have control of discourse practices
very important in enunciated how the
Agora will function and of course if we
remember 5th century Athens the pillar
driving the engine holding up the logos
was the community of dromos do we all
know what the community of dromos right
the community of speed draw knowledge II
remember that the Agora was a democratic
culture and why because 5th century
Athens became an empire because the
Delian League that is they had the
fastest sheep ships to stop Circe's the
second right you guys read this right
okay so we have control of drama graphic
community supporting logos not very
different from today that is the
politics of speed supporting the
discourse of logos and so therefore the
individuals and community who had a
voice over the
Ghora were very much in control of these
two spheres but interestingly enough
there was another community off to the
side here and they were called demos or
demos we get our term democracy from
this and the problem with demos was they
had no access either to logos cultural
practice or dramas speed they basically
had to remain silent
of course democracy now is very vocal as
we all know right but in this time demos
really had nothing left but soma do we
know what soma is raise your hand yes
what is it excellent excellent
so what demos had was soma in order to
disturb the condition of fifth century
logos dromos power anchors and it
created a series of disturbances they
couldn't shout they couldn't speak but
they could manifest themselves
physically and so the battle that took
place here was in developing two
particular circuits of well we should
put it off here to the side of No Mas
right nor most the the vitality of this
century Athens which is that of law and
so the battle of this century was
between those who had no access to logos
but have direct access to soma and could
manifest themselves in the middle in
untimely weight versus dromos and the
logos community over the issue of the
law well hopefully you took good notes
you'll be tested on this tomorrow and
it's been a pleasure speaking to you I
hope we can meet again thank you very
much
I'm sorry I didn't mean to get all
academic on you yes what a virtual
sit-in is yeah yeah yeah basically a URL
and a refresh button and it's the
southeast of flat net is a simple
JavaScript that takes into account how
many people join the flood net and then
it hits the Refresh for every person
that it hits it just automates it so it
hits refresh over and over and over a
refresh basically goes to the server
about its requesting information fries
so it would disturb it that is and it's
only based on the mass community that
joins say for instance hackers are very
clear about this they can technically
and in a technically efficient way take
down most anybody right using
distributed denial-of-service that is
they enslave a series of machines
anonymously they set off packets and we
know in 2000 that Microsoft Yahoo any
kind of strong infrastructure can't
withstand high levels of distributed
denial-of-service and they are
technically efficient but as I said
hackers will tell you that this
JavaScript this HTML is technologically
inefficient it will do nothing less than
kind of create a general disturbance so
I see it more as a symbolic efficacy or
rigid it automates it so what happens
often like for instance when I do
marches in the street and there's a
digital action I leave my computer on
and then I go on the streets and so I
have data body real body kind of merging
together in a political trajectory sure
work there's a combination of to
distinguish well I mean as I said in the
80s I saw it as a performative matrix
that is that performance is the dominant
element and all this and I think
performance allows for activism and the
art element to merge together and while
it is perhaps on occasions difficult to
navigate both conditions I believe that
I was only able to have access to high
levels of power in defining what
activism was because of this kind of
difficulty of seeing it as art or as
activism so in a certain sense you have
to be very tactical about it right so if
you're at the NSA and they say what is
this we say it's HTML conceptualism
right that creates a disturbance and
that creates a kind of a different
trajectory if I'm with hackers then I
deal with the notions of street activism
and hacktivism so it basically depends
on the audience and and the narrative
that's performed and so you know it like
juggle it back and forth sometimes
faster sometimes badly sometimes you
know not at all I mean I was gonna say
in the 80s we used to call ourselves /
artist slash this slash that slash space
so maybe this is kind of a slash slash
right well what happened was that soon
after 9/11 of course there was a
manifestation of terrorism as kind of
the penultimate logos that would define
everything and there was much concern
among street activist and hacktivist as
to what the response would be on in
within the United States specifically
right because there had been a lot of
rapid laws that had played itself out
well the World Economic Forum came here
to New York City not long after the 9/11
so there was all there we decided we're
going to have street actions and we
decided we're gonna do a virtual sit-in
against the World Economic Forum right
because there was a sense globally and I
had been traveling in Australia in all
these places that 9/11 couldn't disrupt
shouldn't disrupt what we had been
building already either the
alter-globalization movement the
activist movement all these tactical
media we should just go forward in terms
of developing a counter discourse to
globalization but there was still
concerns in fear so I spoke to win short
I'll remember the kind of the right-wing
end of information war and I spoke to
dr. Dorothy Denning and I try to get a
sense of how they were reading homeland
security now what happened was that we
very quickly got a sense of the Bush
regime's kind of unbalanced view of
cyber terrorism cyber war and-and-and
cyber terrorism cyber crime was that
during the Clinton era cyber terrorism
cyber war was defined as networks right
they could usually what they say is
terrorists criminals activists right
they don't make any it's all kind of the
same plane but it was networks that were
the dangerous element within the
Clintons reading of of information
culture when the bush regime came in
immediately they changed it from a net
centric view of danger to a strategic
rival view that is they were looking at
China specifically as a strategic tribal
and they started to define all of the
cyber discourse in to focus on cyber
wars
specifically so they kind of forgot and
they put aside all the kind of
net-centric elements that the Clintons
have viewed and they started developing
this kind of theory of cyber war against
China cyber war against Europe and cyber
war against Israel in the Middle East
right because those were seen as the
kind of the big strategic rivals
well of course 9/11 came and they
quickly changed back to the Clintonian
model of net-centric cyber war cyber
terrorism right because suddenly they
saw al-qaeda as part of this network
element well that didn't last very long
and it was about this time that the
World Economic Forum was happening when
they started shifting once more away
from the net centric view to a new view
that was kind of a hybrid between
strategic rival and net centric which
they called the axis of evil which was
minor strategic rivals which now started
being defined as North Korea all these
sort of elements and they viewed it more
as a trans corporate element right so we
came in interactions right about the
shift of that and what happened was we
did have marches quite large and of
course there were cops everywhere and
the virtual sit-in had I think we have
800,000 people worldwide joined the
World Economic Forum site went down
after about seven hours did it go down
because of our virtual sit-in my
response to the people and the officials
and the newspaper was that I felt that
the World Economic Forum's site was as
flimsy as the World Economic Forum's
economic policies so it didn't take very
much for it to crumble and I couldn't
really say that it was us because there
were people inside Waldorf who said
there are wireless PDAs and whatnot
weren't working very well so you know
again this nuance kind of navigation
between did we or didn't win and you
know so it's that question of
performativity and again because it is
performance because it is HTML
conceptualism it is difficult for them
to pinpoint it as a real or how should I
say in techno realism it would be
distributed denial-of-service right but
remember we're transparent we don't hide
we let everybody know what we're going
to do
so it goes against kind of digitally
correct manner and then the other thing
that the NSA was very angry at us and
our hackers and activists net activists
get angry about this is the use of
simulation right because basically the
self at least the flood net as that as
the Socrates does taught us is you know
like paper airplanes it's a simulation
of something and what happens is that a
lot of people are so deeply involved and
passionate about simulation and that
they actually start seeing it as real
right it's sort of like remember nichy's
phrase we shall not be rid of God till
we're rid of grammar in a certain sense
we can change that too we should not be
rid of the matrix until we are rid of
special effects right and in a certain
sense the NS a love special effects
right and one of the elements is they
begin to believe those special effects
are real but because as we said we use
simulation as this up a thesis taught us
so it's difficult for them to say it's
illegal right and when the NSA asked us
about it we said the reason you are so
angry and simulation makes you so angry
is that you feel like the character in
the very first play written in English
here in the United States called my
country cousin there were plays written
in Spanish before this and in my country
cousin a Daniel Boone type characters
invited by his City cousins to go to
come to Philadelphia the cultural center
and they the very first thing they do is
they take him to a play and about midway
through the first act the Daniel Boone
type character runs onstage it's the bad
guy saves the virgin and then everybody
has to explain to him no no no no this
is a play to simulation the bad guy's
not a bad guy the Virgin is not a virgin
so the Pentagon and the NSA were
basically like country bumpkins right
they believed because the simulation
created such sense of emotive realism
that it was actually happening which I
think makes him even angrier because
they can deal with the techno realistic
view of things but it's difficult to get
deeper into the techno realism of the
simulated sense of empathy that occurs
and I think psychologically that really
what is not happening well you series
why we basically what happens is they
they believe that distributed
denial-of-service is taking place this
is under techno realism right that it is
a you know effective tool that will
bring down our networks that's what they
believe right it's sort of like Hamlet
has a sword and you believe the sword is
real and he's going to stab somebody
it's very motive but basically we're
creating a simulation of that sort of
event no what I'm saying is that well
what I'm saying is that I remember I
started off that cyberspace is a mass
consensual hallucination right so
basically people gather by the hundreds
of thousands and we hallucinate that we
are creating an untimely weight of human
beings in a digital space and this
performance creates a certain techno
realistic response by the community of
power right but once the community of
power responds they discover that what
they're responding to is paper airplanes
signifiers that signify something else
right maíam technology so it just makes
them uncomfortable it disturbs them
yes no no no what we're saying is what
we're saying
no no what we're saying is those people
were there they did create a simulated
effect right it's sort of like when you
do a march down the street and you have
Bread and Puppet you basically have a
mass community gathering creating a
gesture now is this a gesture of war all
these sort of things no it's a gesture
of kind of creating a narrative and
basically that happens in this space but
the net art element is that we give it a
tweak right and we say them it's a mass
hallucination based on the weight of
human beings gathering to create a
simulation of meaning a political
meaning of symbolic efficacy as opposed
to technological efficiency right which
is what they see yes well one of the
interesting I mean there were several in
99 several kind of large gatherings
right there were there yes there were
activists who who merged everywhere
using these sort of technologies and of
course there was the building of the
streets up to Seattle I write all those
sort of things and one of the things
that started happening is that in 2000 I
started being invited to hacker
conferences where they had actual
electronic civil disobedience and
hacktivism as part of their dialogue
which in 1991 when I talked to 2600 they
said ooh go away you know it smells now
one of the things that happened at 2600
in 2000 at I think it was called hope
was that after our discussions with cult
of the dead cow and everybody we all are
you know they all went down cult of the
dead cow is a very famous hacker group
okay sorry 2600 is another one and new
york-based and they went down to the
Philadelphia and they joined the street
marches against the Republican
convention which to me was the first
time in which there was a crossover from
a very hardcore hacker community with
the street community the next level was
to get the street community involved
with a certain level of hacktivism
and that started happening when I was
invited by different communities in
Australia and Germany to help develop
and coordinate actions for them one of
the interesting actions was one called
the deportation class action against
Lufthansa where they were had killed
about six or seven people in their
deportations of people in in public
planes because they tied them down and
they put a motorcycle mask on them and
then they tied them down like this and
the mask would hit the windpipe here and
so many of them would die along the way
and what would happen is that there was
an art group and cologne called the
Lufthansa class they dressed up like
pilots and stewardesses and had
Lufthansa exact replicas simulations of
Lufthansa material only as they handed
it out in airports it told him exactly
what was going on with these deportation
stuff right so that was kind of an art
element then there was a 1968 group
against political prisoners very active
you know out of Biderman HOF all that
kind of community hardcore they never
used any online kind of element and so
they started integrating with the
Cologne people and then came the border
hack people and they started joining and
they started trying to integrate and
develop kind of a way for these
communities to talk and then there were
four individuals from the Chaos Computer
Club whose never liked me very much they
decided to leave Chaos Computer Club and
set up a virtual sit-in so they all
started and they set up a server for all
these communities so this was the first
time in Germany that a hardcore Street
activist community going back to the 60s
started talking to a conceptual art
group and cologne and started talking to
kind of tactical media people the border
hack people and then these chaos
computer kids started developing a
virtual sit-in right so and that was in
2000 and they started integrating they
invited me to come and cross all of
Germany on a you know every day I was in
a different city and my job was number
one talk to the media
number two talk to the activists right
and you know try to balance it out and
the media and the activists both had a
question is this real right and so I
would tell the media well it's virtually
real it's really virtual I would tell
the activist well it's virtually real
it's really virtual right but what
happened was that we all focused that
month and you know I went all over and
we went inside the shareholders meeting
we did the virtual sit-in there were
protests outside so kind of all accrued
together and it went extremely well the
site went down anyway there was a lot of
shifts the pilots union joined Lufthansa
and said they would never fly another
deportation class all that sort of stuff
and what started happening is I started
being invited to hack labs across Europe
and an activist groups right and
basically you started seeing a movement
but by 2000 had grown into a wide
network right the intercontinental
Indymedia rise he had you know there was
so many layers that were brought
together so at least to me that's kind
of the arc of activism where you all
those elements do become porous and
activists can either use it or not use
it hackers can use it or not use it so
and we did actions against Ashkelon and
all these kind of things well yes
somebody had raised a hand yes
just in this question of stimulation
giving sort of protected or we
strategically viable position for you
know for activism what happens when
simulation technology an object of
legislation then does that undermine the
position that you have carved out for
yourself insular staying one step ahead
of regulatory activity because I'm just
interested in this it seems like you are
well I mean that's as I said if we look
at this the the conflict has ever been
between logos dramas right and demos
soma
those are the conflict points and it's
all about Nomos right so I think there
are occasions in the trajectory of the
arc of the work where you know basically
logos and ramos are going to shut down
and they're gonna define normals in the
Agora and certainly we see right now you
know all the kind of gated logic gated
communities expanded techno efficiency I
would say it's simulated I think it's
direct techno efficiency and so yes it's
a for demos and Soma it is a very
dangerous space and in that I think a
lot of communities not just hacktivists
activists you know you name it feel
outside of how do we name normals for
ourselves once more and I think that
often happens I mean I remember back in
the 70s I mean Richard Nixon you know
being the penultimate kind of runs faily
in whatever position and that kind of
imploded and then suddenly demos and
Soma
emerged for a very long time and then so
you have these kind of cyclical periods
why you hope in every cycle is that
you've tweaked it enough
that some of the elements of the
connection between soma and demo stays
right and so at this point in time I
feel fairly positive that the stuff that
we did earlier in terms of Deming and
you know all that sort of stuff I just
saw recently is still fairly stable and
that because we speak from this other
discourse of electronic civil
disobedience which is as apple pie
you know it's American right it's
Thoreau 1848 we didn't make a commie
didn't make it out right that's pretty
Hardy stalk that did it so I think it
does have a chance it does have an
opportunity I think what they will do to
crush it though and we certainly saw
that even though Richard Clarke came out
and yelled and you know which is good
when he was the head of cyber theory and
cyber information war theory he was very
much into kind of the hysteria of cyber
war and he was really pumping it up and
you know III would like that effect not
to linger and how it linked how can we
stop that well obviously you guys having
a dialogue about it
tactical media net artists act you know
the more transparent we are even though
Porter Yard says transparency is evil
in this particular case I like that evil
element to work for us that is that
transparency and you know this is kind
of an open burrito right hacktivism so
we can stuff it with all sorts of stuff
but in the end it would be nice to
grapple with Nomis in a clearer way and
maybe that will come out of you know
deep thought from you know places like
Columbia what's interesting is I taught
a course of on the electronic civil
disobedience at NYU
theory and practice and we did an action
against NYU which went quite well of
course the FBI came there were all going
on you know blah blah blah but we got
the information about why we were doing
it on all that stuff on a semantic level
and it was interesting just to look at
the amount of discourse that had emerged
on electronic civil disobedience on
activism but wasn't being developed by
me or you know it was kind of all these
Outsiders playing with it and to me that
was quite exciting and the kids were
very good you
in focusing and understanding and and
tweaking and we were able to out a
certain kind of vile elements in the
business school from the argentinian
government that had somehow escaped
prison and ended up in as a chair
position over there and so again because
it was simulation all this sort of stuff
the the school had to respond to it but
it couldn't respond to it directly
because it was a class and it was being
taught you know it's all sorts of all
sorts of little nebulous things so i
don't know yeah yeah well yeah and so
again no most on a minor pedagogical
scale yeah maybe i've dream sake go go
you